what was the the issue with written
house what happened with the shirt that
was worn if you can talk about that a
little bit because there was a little
bit of controversy with that
yeah i mean we got we got kind of thrown
in the center of that i mean the start
of it was um
and i it's weird that i have to say this
so much but going into that um i always
when you watch that video for me kyle
renthouse defended himself with a
firearm legally and i've been a huge
second amendment um proponent my entire
life i mean i'm one of the like og guys
on youtube that started making comedy
videos um well when the shirt came out
it was a huge mix up with like kind of a
sponsorship essentially and
um
it was
pretty much said that we'd sponsored him
and we didn't sponsor him and so when we
put a statement out saying we didn't
sponsor him people took that as we don't
support him drastically two different
things um and also like we had us we had
kind of a weak response to be honest
with you we we were caught off guard and
we were we kind of [ __ ] it up to be
honest with you like oh no [ __ ] yeah
like okay i think i think uh there
wasn't clear and concise like this is
what we believe it was scattered
information and then people ran with a
false narrative and
you know when you look back at certain
things like that like i'm not a pr
expert man i was carrying a gun
professionally like eight years ago so
um
but it is what it is and i think most
people see now especially even after the
company went public we have not veered
from anything that we've ever done like
at the time where most people might
change their brand position we're going
hard in the paint with their support for
second amendment i mean i just did a
great podcast i thought with the
firearms policy coalition who i think is
the leader in second amendment um
the lawsuits and everything they do to
protect the second amendment so we're
out there doing what we believe in and
i'm a constitutionalist and
most people know that but question for
you sure
in that moment because i remember one
time you know media matters came after
me and daily beast came after me we were
having an event i think with
uh uh uh kobe bryant the late kobe
bryant and president bush and jordan
peterson we put you know six that you
were at this event right six thousand
people we put in the room and it's it's
an incredible event phenomenal event
that we had next thing you know patrick
but david this i'm like what the hell is
going on so we came back and we called
them up and we addressed them we handled
we had a lengthy call i was just coming
back on a flight the incentive trip we
had with our guys but we didn't have a
publicist at the time we didn't have a
you know a big sunshine sacks in new
york saying here's how you handle it
first time when you say this this is the
script
when that happened to you guys did you
have somebody that was kind of directing
you guys were you took the council from
them or was it more here's how we're
reacting to this crisis
for me it was more i was just so taken
back that people on like our side would
be like that we went woke and we're not
we're anti-2a i was i was actually more
confused than anything
and part of that too is that i didn't
really realize the importance of that
situation for the second amendment
whereas if he would have been found
guilty
what that would have done for case law
didn't know that until probably a couple
months i set down the lawyer and a
friend he was like this is why this
specific instance matters so much i went
oh i got it but then also right i look
in the sense of
i'm a veteran owned and operated coffee
company that puts veterans first and i
like i'm a huge gun guy personally and
so like i didn't necessarily know why
the company had to make a statement in
in that situation was it was just very
confusing at the time i feel like and so
i think to your point um you make
mistakes you learn from them and all you
can do is be exactly who you are and
stay authentic and i think we've done
exactly that how
just again just to finish this up i want
to move on from this topic but if if you
like the next time around something like
this happen what's going to be the
different approach is there like a new
sys because we created a system for
ourselves because if you don't know how
to deal with the immediate they're going
to bully you and they're not going to
stop because they'll keep picking at you
what is the new
approach that you guys are planning on
taking if something like this happens
well in our initial statement yeah we
said we believe in the judicial system
pretty much he was like verbatim that um
i don't want to say verbatim because i
don't speak a term but it was we like we
it was implied that we were fully
supporting kyle and we believe he was
going to be found innocent
but there was still gray area in there
so probably ford i'm going to be so
clear and concise with my statements
because obviously anybody can take
we see the news that has done it so many
times since over the years they take an
interview they misplaced the statement
and they make you look like an [ __ ]
so you know what it almost is here's
here's the craziest thing
what it almost is and you hear this over
and over and over again until it happens
to you
man you know to apologize or not to
apologize right to to
bow down or to say listen this is what
we stand for the guy has the freedom to
wear that shirt this is what he supports
did we ask him to wear that shirt the
guy chose to wear that shirt how come
you don't call people the next time
there's a shooting and the guy's wearing
nike akanaki doesn't get called out for
that how come you know puma come whoever
it is i don't know who wears puma but
how come these other guys don't get
called out for that and but but this
specific area it's because of hey this
is what you stand for you're
conservative boom let's go after this so
you know it's it's almost if you are
specifically if you're conservative
it backfires if you try to
play the diplomatic game they will keep
bullying you over and over and over
again yeah plus there's no doubt where
you guys stand and you're very
articulate so you don't really make
mistakes if a microphone goes in front
of you so i think you have that as an
advantage i think people are getting
tired of apologies i think
a few people are gonna we're just
exhausted from it don't you think a few
people are just going like you you watch
some of these commentators right now
that oh and comedians and you see what
happened to dave chappelle in
minneapolis i'm not sure if you guys
talked about that where show got
canceled last week at first avenue but i
think people are just exhausted of
apologizing and hearing apologies all
the time like
who has the time to be offended by
everything like i if i said something
that offended a lot of people i honestly
wouldn't care i mean like why would i
want to go out of my way to apologize to
somebody in topeka that i've never met
before so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]